Nikki hailey is of course leaving her
position as ambassador to the United
Nations we may not like Nick hate Nikki
Haley's politics
I don't like Nikki Haley's politics but
she's more or less qualified for the
position as qualified as many
ambassadors are anyway let's sort of put
it at that Donald Trump is appointing
former Fox News anchor Heather now irt's
as ambassador to the United Nations to
replace nikki Haley there's an idea
right
more recently after her stint at Fox
News Heather now it has been spokeswoman
for the State Department Donald Trump
calling her very talented very smart and
very quick and says that she will be
respected by all hmm what's worse making
people ambassadors who pay for those
positions is normally done not with the
ambassador to the UN right like I've
talked before about how under Obama
under Trump big fundraisers and Friends
of the president's it's sort of standard
practice that you can kind of buy
yourself an ambassadorship but usually
it's like you know ambassador to the
Seychelles or something like that
this is much worse because this is the
United Nations and it's also kind of an
attack on the United Nations it's sort
of suggesting that the UN is a joke I
don't know if deliberately or
subconsciously when you say I'm gonna
put Fox News lady in as my ambassador to
the United Nations in a way you're
saying you don't take the United Nations
seriously and you think about the entire
thing as a joke the only saving grace
here Pat to trump pursuing his reality
show administration within the United
States government is that Heather now
irt's confirmation would Heather not now
its nomination would require Senate
confirmation I can only imagine that
those would be fascinating confirmation
hearings I suppose the other saving
grace is that he didn't choose Jeanine
Pirro because that would be a lot worse
we do know that the Fox News to White
House pipeline that's an that's in
strong shape right now it is and Heather
nowart has no political experience
has no policymaking experience I don't
know exactly what she's going to do but
imagine for a moment if Hillary Clinton
were president and appointed I don't
know Rachel Maddow as it mass ambassador
to the United Nations or if Barack Obama
had appointed Anderson Cooper or Don
Lemon the right would lose it and they
are actually now playing this game where
they say you're questioning Heather now
irt's fitness for the job that sexist
and misogynist which of course is utter
and complete nonsense and even they
don't believe it and in a way now it's
kind of the perfect thing for a perfect
fit right she has no experience as I
said she's totally unqualified as I said
she doesn't know anything about policy
but she will go with whatever Donald
Trump says and it'll serve the purpose
of being a de facto attack on the United
Nations Trump thinks so lowly of the
United Nations that he will appoint
Heather Nauert as the Ambassador truly a
joke and this is why the world is
laughing to the cheers of millions of
Trumpets in the United States